We'll be experimenting with D3 on the Udacity course page for this class.
Since D3 is a client side JavaScript library you can load it onto any web
page that you're on and start playing around with the elements of HTML or
SVG contained on that page.
If you're on any of the web pages of the data visualization class.
D3 should already be loaded.
But if you're on a web page that does not have D3 loaded,
you can simply copy the D3 source and paste it in the web console.
I will be using the Google Chrome browser throughout this course.
But, any modern browser should have all of the same functionality of
a JavaScript console and an HTML inspector.
To open the JavaScript console, we can go to the Tool bar of Chrome accessed
from the upper right corner of the browser window, scroll down to the sub menu
of Tools, and from Tools you can see here that we can view source,
access the Developer Tools or go into the JavaScript Console.
As you notice here it pops up a window on the bottom of
my browser that let's me enter and execute JavaScript.
Unfortunately at Zipfian Academy we do not have the engineers or
great production team that Udacity has to create such
a compelling online education platform.
What we do have, however, is a knowledge of D3 and JavaScript.
So instead of building our own platform, let's usurp Udacity and
pretend that we have their own platform as well.
We can do this by changing the branding of Udacity's logo,
maybe some elements with the course, and
actually change anything else on the webpage that we may want to.